we have an unexpected fox news alert for
you something has just happened in Iraq
the situation there heating up very
quickly without any debate here in
Washington a rocky television has just
confirmed that Kasim sulemani a former
general in Iran's Revolutionary Guard
and a commander of the Kurds Force has
been killed in a rocket attack
apparently initiated by the United
States near the Baghdad Airport along
with the top official in the Iraqi
Shiite militia now what were they doing
in Iraq unclear but his death comes
several days after intentions kind of
came out into the open in that country
last week if you've been following us
you know an American civilian contractor
was killed by militants in Iraq the US
government blamed that attack on Iran
and it's retaliated with strikes in
response protesters blockaded the US
Embassy in Baghdad it's basically where
we were when the show started something
defense secretary Mark Esper warned that
the United States is prepared to launch
additional pre-emptive military strikes
against Iranian interests in the region
which apparently are what we are seeing
right now now again there's been
virtually no debate or even discussion
about this but America appears to be
lumbering toward a new Middle East war
and we have to say it's one that
official Washington has wanted for
decades for example disgraced national
security advisor John Bolton has made it
his life's mission cisterna a war with
Iran and tonight Bolton may be finally
getting his wish should you be happy
about that
that's the question well the last time
we took John Bolton's advice in the
region Iran became far more powerful
than it was before before we took John
Bulls advice why cuz things were never
quite as simple as they claimed they are
in Washington in this case the very
people demanding action against Iran
tonight the ones telling you the Persian
Menace is the greatest threat we face
are the very same ones demanding that
you ignore the invasion of America now
in progress from the south the millions
the tens of millions of foreign
nationals living among us illegally the
torrent more significantly of Mexican
narcotics that has killed and disabled
entire generations of Americans nobody
cares
in case you haven't noticed pay no
attention to all of that these very same
people tell us the real threat is Iran
well
they're liars and they don't care about
you they don't care about your kids
they're reckless and incompetent and you
should keep all of that in mind as war
with Iran looms closer tonight
Kurt Mills is the senior writer at the
American Conservative he joins us now so
Kurt this is unfolding even as we speak
where could it go from here
well like you said if you like the Iraq
war Tucker we're back with the sequel
the Iran war I would say the deep
concern is look a general and the
Iranian forces being assassinated is not
necessarily something to mourn or
begrudge the u.s. getting involved in
it's right question great the question
is though is this a Franz Ferdinand
moment is this a situation where a great
power gets involved with middle-tier
power and gets the world into a world
war Iran I think is a problem for the US
and its allies in the region but it is
not an existential threat like China or
Russia China or Russia particularly
China would love to see another decade
or two of Americans my age dying in the
sand for no particular purpose well
that's that's exactly it's not that
anyone I think in the United States has
particular affection for Iran or trust
in government much much less it's the
Revolutionary Guard or the Kurds forces
of course not but it's the intemperate
with which the foreign policy
establishment of Washington describes
the threat that I think makes sensible
people nervous that Iran is the greatest
threat facing mean it's so prima facie
absurd that it makes you wonder what
their actual agenda is it's a joke it's
a joke I mean I think the real question
is why do we still have troops there so
you see the Baghdad embassy protests and
to be clear this is not just an embassy
this is a fortress it's been a fortress
since we took out Saddam in 2003 and
American troops there if we're not going
to re in X the country are effectively
hostages they're just they're sent there
so the question the president who I
think rightfully ran in 2016 against the
bush legacy the question is does he want
to reinvade Iraq I understand there are
people in his cabinet that are selling
him that Iran is not Iraq
the fact of the matter is it Ron is
quite similar to Iraq we're talking
about Iraq 16 years later it's still
Iraq in order to counter Iran I think
the I think the choice is clear the
resident should contain Iranian
influence in the region which should
avoid a hot war which we are barreling
towards at all costs so my sense of it
is is that the president doesn't seek
war and he's but he's wary of it
particularly in an election year but I
think he was elected on the promise that
he would avoid Wars except when
absolutely necessary but there are a lot
of people around him and certainly in
the city of Washington who've been
preparing for this agitating for
Bolton's one of many for an awfully long
time and you wonder if it's possible
that he might be outmaneuvered by them
and that we might we might find
ourselves a move toward war despite what
the president wants right so I think the
president United States is convictions
on this matter are sincere but I think
it's relevant particularly extremely
relevant in matters of war and peace and
life and death who he staffed his
administration with I know Bolton is a
bugbear for you but in some ways Bolton
because he's so flamboyant and some
infamous and notorious he actually was a
bit of a problem for the Iran Hawk
crusade more middle weight more
circumspect managers like Robert see
O'Brien the Bolton successor might
actually be more affected at Trojan
horsing what I think would be a tragedy
in the Middle East Iran is not Iraq it's
twice as big it'd be twice as bad were
weaker than we were 16 years ago if
president george w bush struggled to win
reelection 2004 if Trump does this he's
cooked I think that's right
criminals great to see you tonight thank
you for that